have you had conversations about the
future of Shazam it's a really enjoyable
uh extension of the DCU I hope everyone
goes and sees this movie if they do then
I I think I think we'll have a better
shot of making more in the future but I
think that's the goal the wizard gave me
superpowers and then everybody got super
powers where's everyone going
to fight crime
okay
now everyone's kind of like doing their
own thing and I'm the only one trying to
keep it together
Zachary we're back we're back the Shazam
Leah's back this is Emily's back it's
been it's been some time yeah what is
what where do we find Billy where is he
emotionally yeah well uh so yeah it's
been about within the movie uh it's been
about three-ish years right so he was
like 14 15 the first movie 17 almost 18
in this one uh which is a market
difference for a young man uh there's a
lot that changes in that time
specifically and um I think that
emotionally you know the first one
he was he was jaded he'd been bouncing
around the Foster system he couldn't
find a family that you know he connected
to that loved him that he wanted to be
with and now and by the end of the movie
he's found that and so now three years
on he's almost 18 years old he's almost
graduating out of the foster care system
and he's really terrified that he's now
about to lose the family that he fought
so hard and looked so long to to find
um so emotionally he's very much in that
spot and simultaneously he is you know
the leader of this super team of of his
siblings and um so he feels a lot of
responsibility there to keep everyone
together which is also kind of part like
just keeping the family together and
what's going on underneath but also
genuinely trying to live up to his
calling you know he was chosen to be the
you know Earth's Mightiest mortal to be
the the you know the chosen one the
champion and he feels like he's bumbling
that and and failing that a lot you know
but I think that's the Imposter syndrome
that we can all kind of relate to and
tap into yeah right now yeah I hear you
well and the shazamly too they've gotten
kind of famous or more Infamous in
Philadelphia sure yeah what is your
favorite headline that you read about
the the fiascos oh I mean uh probably
that probably that one I just love the
juxtaposition of us going and and we're
saving people and we're we think we're
doing great and we're like all right now
we just gotta keep this bridge from
falling apart and then the first
headline is Bridge collapses
um it's just a funny you know it's a
great just kind of straight cut to joke
and I always appreciate those you know
yeah and there's a new family that comes
in these sisters these goddesses yeah
what is it like to be Spartan kicked by
Helen Mirren
we are Sparta yeah totally
um she I mean honestly uh it's uh it's a
dream uh to not necessarily get Spartan
kicked uh by anyone for that matter but
if it's gonna be easy it might as well
be Helen Mirren
um she and Lucy and Rachel are three
just fantastic actors and and women and
just jumped right into the sandbox with
us there was no egos there was no
nothing he was like how can we all have
fun together and you know this movie is
really a lot of it is predicated upon
the fun that we're all having together
on and off screen because that gets you
know kind of imbued into the movie
itself and hopefully to the audience and
Helen is everything you want her to be
she's I mean she's a Dame but she
doesn't throw it in your face you know
Dame Helen I I just I just heard she uh
broke her finger on set and didn't tell
anybody because she wanted to keep doing
her own stunts oh yeah no I think the
entire world including myself found out
from The Graham Norton Show that she did
but she had a janky Pinky from us doing
those stunts that's my Shazam finger I
had no idea but she's such a trooper
like she was so in it to win it like she
she didn't I you know we had stunt
doubles to take care of certain things
because they're just from a liability
standpoint you can't do everything yeah
because of that reason because you might
end up breaking your finger or whatever
whatever happened
um but she was so there and present and
rolling up her sleeves and like how can
we go have fun how can we do this she's
she's everything she's such an icon
amazing okay so you've originally
auditioned for Freddie Freeman Adam
Brody's role right yeah you also played
fandral and Thor yeah I'm curious what
other like close
superhero or villain calls that you've
had well I mean I I I've been kicking
around in this town for a minute uh so
I've auditioned for a few a few
different roles like uh just for Captain
America way back in the day
um you know that was Chris Evansville I
mean you know you try as an actor you
try to let go of things if they don't
come your way because obviously that
wasn't meant to be yeah I came really
close uh to get Star-Lord um in
Guardians of the Galaxy but that was not
to be and that was Chris's role at Chris
Pratt's role and I'm sure there have
been a few others along the way but look
and all of it was to lead me to this
role it was all to lead me to this role
I I don't know that I could think of a
role that I'd rather play to be honest
and I love superheroes across the board
but to get to you know as a kid I was so
in love with the idea of like I loved
Tom Hanks in big and I loved Christopher
Reeves and Superman and I got to do
basically the the love child of those
two movies yeah in Shazam and uh yeah
it's it's the bee's knees I love it so
much I mean I've been lucky enough to
interview you a few times for this and I
feel like you are really bad
I mean I I definitely tried to hold on
to
uh
uh Youth and certain childlike qualities
in my life as long as I can being an
actor you get to kind of do that a
little bit because so much your job is
literally make believe it's playing
dress-up and using your imagination and
having them you know exercising wonder
and all of those things and I just love
having fun in general so I think all of
that stacked into like oh maybe this guy
you know when I just auditioned for for
Super Freddy not knowing it was super
Freddy by the way it was a hush-hush
thing we didn't know what the roles were
it was some random scene that they had
written
about a water boy on an NBA team who
there's like a timeout and the coach is
angry with the team and he's like you
guys are all sucking it up and he goes
Johnson and he points to the water board
he goes you're in and the and the water
boy strips off of his water boy clothes
and he's got a jersey and everything
underneath and he's ready to play ball
he's actually pretty good at playing
ball but he's like dry heaving while
he's doing it uh because he's so nervous
and that ended up being the secret
audition for Super Freddy and I
submitted that they saw that but based
on the audition they were like this
actually feels like this could be more
Shazam than than this other character
and then a week later I was Shazam so
wow yeah it was very magical very very
Supernatural I mean I really feel like
those doors just kind of open for me and
I'm so grateful that David and Peter and
new line and Warner Brothers and all the
powers that be
believed in me in the same way that the
wizard sees Billy and says you're the
champion and Billy's like well I'm the
Champion this doesn't make any sense I
really felt that I was like I can't
believe that they see this in me when I
can't see it in myself but that was also
a huge part of my own mental health
Journey that was all this stuff that was
going on and me not recognizing that I
didn't know how to love myself or value
myself and then once I start once that
all clicked and it started to happen all
of a sudden it was like boom boom boom
here's these doors that open up and yeah
you are worthy and yeah you can be this
titular character of the superhero
franchise and I was like wow thank you
God this is so cool speaking of the
powers of B I know it's a little out of
your hands with Peter Safran I know
you're friends with James Gunn and
they're taking over DC students
have you had conversations about the
future of Shazam because I think that
would be the biggest loss to not have
the Shazam lay around anymore I listen I
I've talked to uh Peter a good bit we're
going to talk more uh on on this tour
um
certainly the idea is to continue the
character this world I mean it's a
really enjoyable uh extension of the DCU
you know it it it has DNA that a lot of
the other characters and extensions
don't necessarily have because we are a
more family you know young and old male
and female and everything in between you
know kind of um franchise
and it comes with a lot of fun it's very
it's very you know a throwback you know
like to amblin and lucasfilm and all
that kind of stuff like Goonies and and
uh uh Indiana Jones and all those things
that evoke that kind of Adventure in you
and so I think certainly the idea is to
keep it going
I hope everyone goes and sees this movie
if they do I I think I think we'll have
a better shot of making more in the
future but I think that's the goal
[Music]